[Laughter]
just for all the titles oh boy so I went
and saw movie not anything I had planned
to see not my usual wheelhouse I went
with a friend who I haven't seen a
little bit um I don't who I don't see as
often as I would like to if I'm being
completely honest and she really wanted
to see this and I said okay how sure I I
didn't think I was going to like it but
who knows I've been surprised every now
and then romantic comedies actually do
it for me it's rare but it can happen
and she seems excited to see it so we
gave it a go that movie was last
Christmas Hey
Wow I'm just gonna I'm just gonna ramble
and talk about what this thing was cuz I
don't know how well it did at the box
office I don't think that great there
were only two of of um the theater gran
has been out for a little bit but I
don't even feel bad sliding this off
because you know about 40 minutes into
the movie she and I started snarling at
each other over what we were watching so
this movie takes us title and claims to
be inspired by the George Michael song
last Christmas
and and apparently Emma Thompson who is
in this we'll get back to that co-wrote
and co-produced this now I like Emma
Thompson but I okay so looking at the
trailers to this thing it looked like
you're fairly standard may be slightly
above hallmark original movie kind of
Christmas romantic comedy fluff that's
what it looked like it looked it looked
harmless and the only reason that it
wasn't on something like the Hallmark
Channel or Netflix airing after the
sequel to the Christmas prints is
because it had higher caliber actors you
know it's got Emilia Clarke
it's got I cannot remember his name now
but the guy who was the male lead in
crazy rich Asians who's wonderfully
charming Emma Thompson who I mentioned
she is in this as well and there are a
few other people who I recognized here
and there Peter Serafinowicz and and
there were some others as well it's got
it's got a decent cast they did they
licensed not only last Christmas from
George Michael but it appears a whole
big chunk of his catalog because most of
the music that you hear and this is
George Michael so apparently they
decided to get their money's worth out
of that and so it you know it just
looked it looked like it was gonna be
cheesy and fine so well it starts and
Emilia Clarke is a drunken promiscuous
mess she doesn't quite charming Lee and
actually that's worth noting the actors
are not bad in this I don't entirely
know why Emma Thompson felt the need to
play the role that she does but but even
she's not bad in it so the acting is
fine the acting is not
what's like what what is going on Oh
Michelle Yeoh that's another one who's
in this so oh boy
so yeah Emilia Clarke is a drunken
unstable mess and she is being repeated
she basically just keeps getting drunk
and screwing up and keeps getting kicked
out of home after home flat after flat
burning through her friends effectively
until they write her off and refusing to
go back in with her parents and she
works at a year-round Christmas shop
although the fact that it's year round
is incidental because it is actually
Christmas season for this and she works
for Michelle Yeoh who who is called
Santa and she's she's just kind of
playing the dragon lady boss and there's
this really weird subplot where this guy
who I guess is German comes in and
there's like I guess it's supposed to be
instant chemistry between him and
Michelle Yeoh as characters except they
overplayed it it was so like huh and
like weird they're just saying words to
fill the space and they're just they're
just trying to be keeping connected with
each other and it's these weird awkward
lines but it was so intense I made the
assumption that like this was somebody
she knew a long time ago ahead see like
this fit this was way too strong to be
at these people have never seen each
other before except that's what it was
they'd literally never seen each other
before were just staring and saying
awkward lines like would you like to buy
this screeching Christmas Gibbon and I'm
not even making that up
it was a sparkly shiny little Gibbon
that screeched apparently that was
supposed to be funny the humor is very
okay that's funny I guess
not a lot of it's funny a lot of us just
kind of weird they're not even bad jokes
they're just weird
jokes it's like that that's not quite
bizarre enough to be a non sequitur but
it's too weird to just be so Emilia
Clarke character is an aspiring singer
and performer and she has auditions she
keeps failing and she randomly runs into
this guy Tom and the two of them you
know start hanging out he's he is very I
would actually say aggressively charming
like he's got so many charming quirks
it's like dude this is this is too much
like he kind of dances whatever he he
goes anywhere he's always like ah you
need to look up and either like keep
like finding reasons to have her look up
and it's it's it's weird thankfully she
does point out that he's weird um but at
the same time he is like super charming
and he certainly yeah there's it doesn't
given how nondiscrimination she's been
shown to be there doesn't seem to be a
reason for her to point out that he's
weird she doesn't she seems to go for a
pretty wide variety of people who don't
seem to have all that much going for
them and I know all this sounds pretty
standard and distorted is except that
about 40 minutes in my friend and I
realized there isn't really plot going
on Emilia Clarke is there and yes she's
kind of a mess but she's not really on a
personal journey and Tom seems to you
know want her to do better but isn't
really making it a mission to try and
fix her and in fact they go for long
stretches without the two of them being
together so their relationship is there
but it doesn't seem to be central and
there's all the side stuff with her with
Emilia Clarke Skerritt Kate that's her
that's the character's name with Kate's
parents who are from former Yugoslavia
which I mentioned Emma Thompson so yeah
she plays Kate's mother
who's from Yugoslavia so you have Emma
Thompson one of the great English actors
delivers amazing you know dialogue
talking this stilted broken Yugoslavian
accent I don't know why and so if
anybody has heard anything about this at
all you may have heard that there's a
twist and I kind of figured there was
gonna be some sort of twist regarding
Tom cuz there were odd things
he kept odd hours he was missing from a
lot of things he seemed to be hard for
her to track down sometimes what I
thought what it wasn't gonna end up
being was that like he was us maybe he
was a squatter or he was homeless cuz
there was sort of a running thing of
people in worse situations than Kate and
like maybe was gonna turn out to be
somebody like that I didn't know my
friend who I went with she actually
called this about a little less than an
hour into the movie she called what the
twist was and she said to me what she
thought it was and I laughed harder than
I did in anything at the movie because
I'm like haha boy wouldn't that be crazy
if they were stupid enough to do that so
if I were to tell you that nobody
besides Kate actually interacts with Tom
nobody else has any lines with him there
doesn't seem to be a lot of
acknowledgement of his existence when
she asked people about Tom they're like
who if I tell you that what would you
think the twist might end up being
there's a couple of options I suppose I
suppose he could just be a figment of
her imagination or like an angel or it
could be what they did which is that
he's dead and she's dating a ghost and a
story that in no way prior to the reveal
of this fact in like the last 15 minutes
or so has established any sort of even
vague spiritual ghostly supernatural or
even really religious in the nation's to
justify having had a ghost just hanging
around and like bonding with Kate and it
kids think it's better was just to say
that it gets more insane and stupider
because it's not just that he's a ghost
so it gets laid in very early on that
about a year ago kate underwent some
sort of major surgery she was quite sick
and we find out about two-thirds the way
in that what happened was she has she
almost died and she had a heart
transplant it's not Tom's dead he was
the heart donor
but he had an accident and he was an
organ donor so it's his heart it hurts
because Christmas is this thing how did
people as child is directed by Paul Feig
I don't love every movie the man's ever
made
not an untalented director and you know
usually he gets he has a better taste in
scripts than this I don't why why why
why was this written what like Emma
Thompson I get she wrote it she produced
it she's got friends you know in high
places she can pull in the town but like
she can't generate out of nowhere the
budget it would have taken to do this so
somebody who looked at this script and
this idea and of a ton of George Michael
music and said yes let's throw tens of
millions of dollars at that last
Christmas last Christmas holy crap
I've got a you know I've had stuff break
me before like by depressing the crap
out of me black mirrors done that I've
had stuff break me because of how angry
it's made me but I don't think I've had
anything break me just out of WTF this
[Laughter]
last Christmas did anyone else see this
thing or whatever your thoughts of our
comments section let me have it
patreon much appreciated subscribe like
Oh have a great holiday don't see this I
mean I guess go ahead if you want I've
spoiled it for you but I can't tell you
what did you guess at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just a crazy
person from the meetings until next time
this council is adjourned
what
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]